there's some new feminist Marvel movie
out which one based on Captain Marvel
which I labored through for the daily
wire some years ago whenever it came out
it's with some woman Brie Larson as the
actress in it and it was really just
Dreadful and then they made a sequel to
it called the Marvels which just came
out and it appears to be the lowest
opening weekend in Marvel franchise
history it pulled in 47 million bucks so
this is good for the culture because I
don't I don't like the Marvel movies
generally I really don't like feminist
movies unless they're at least uh
provocative or interesting or show me
something from a new angle and it's not
just Joe Scarboro tier you know my
enemies are fascists kind of stuff but
but that rarely happens in in any movie
especially feminist movies so I don't
like that and then you combine the the
two so you've got this really shallow
formulaic movie that just inserts a
bunch of woke girl boss uh catchphrases
into it and it's just absolutely
unbearable